so I'm Nabila Chaudhary I work really  closely with Elissa at sea far on the  pan-canadian AI strategy help to manage  the the sea fired chairs program and  when the occasion calls for it kortnee  poster sessions so I want to thank our  judges today so we had some of our CCI  chairs volunteer to be judges and I'm  just gonna get into it so we actually  had two runners-up today so I'm going to  call them up to the stage  so the first runner so this it's a tie  so discounted reinforcement learning is  not an optimized problem  Abhishek make from you of a  and online continual learning with  maximally interfered retrieval so I have  to co-presenters here Lucas and Massimo  Quechua from mullah Miguel and so the  first prize goes to you boy and barinov  sparse variation variational inference  Bayesian core asides from scratch  [Applause]